let's get back to what we still call the
phone lines although they're really at
this point just
internet bits we do take calls via
discord you can find our discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to james from new
york city you're on the air
hi um wow this is the first time i came
on the discord so
thank you pretty surprised uh i was just
wondering uh
y'all i there may be like a slight lead
up to my question uh
i wanted to talk about the new york
senatorial race uh new york city
okay uh because currently like half of
the voters are undecided at this point
so it's kind of just open
obviously we got you know yang um now
hold on a second you're saying mayoral
right because you said senatorial
oh sorry mayor mayoral okay good good
good yeah and like even recently um the
chief of the division of uh thoracic
surgery at mount sinai or raja flores
went into the race so it's just kind of
all out in the open i just i guess my
question would be uh
who is from what you've seen uh your
preferred candidate if you have one and
how do you feel about the race in
general listen i'm not really taking a
position
on it because i've not examined all of
the candidates obviously andrew yang
has been a guest on this program i think
he has great ideas
you know one of the critiques of yang
as a presidential candidate i think
serves him well
in theory as mayor which is that he's
more of like a project management guy
where he sees a lot of political issues
as
we just kind of need to take a
consultancy approach a kind of
technocrat
and new york city mayor is one of those
things where
you're going to have a bunch of people
hating you no matter what you do
and someone like yang who's just going
to sort of come in and take this project
management approach
and be guided hopefully by data and
i'm idealizing here but like ignore the
the sort of hyperbole around the fringes
he might be quite well suited to the job
now i know that there are people who
will say
you know he's really lived upstate like
he has this place in the city he's not
really a new york city resident
okay you know fine like we can we can
debate all that stuff but i think some
of what
made him less appealing as a
presidential candidate makes him
potentially better suited as new york
city mayor
yeah it was just a really interesting
political move when i uh i saw that you
know
yes well are you supporting him
um i'm not sure yet i think i'll just
kind of wait to see how things go
because again like
i think i'm kind of in the majority of
the people are kind of undecided at this
point
okay okay yeah i mean i thought he was
leading i thought he was leading the
primary
but i haven't seen it like 28 of the
vote or something
oh it's not he has a plurality but not
at this point well listen if there's 10
candidates you don't need a majority
oh of course but you know you people
drop out you know sure it's true
all right very good james we'll follow
the race for sure
james all right james is done very good
um yeah that's an interesting race
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on
you can often see me wearing my ventura
watch on the show
mine is the gunmetal vessel model i'm a
big fan of the metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over 26 000
five-star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman